what's goodie welcome back to hot breath
the show where you learn comedy from the
pros
i am your host comedian joel byers with
my co-host
guiness my dog and we're here
to give you a tight minute
video podcast about
how to create a tight five minute set
so first step in creating your five
minute set
you want to open and close
with your strongest jokes there's a rule
of thumb
whatever that phrase even means there's
a rule of thumb
where you actually open with your second
strongest and close
with your strongest strongest
whichever way you do it you just want to
know you want to open with a laugh as
quick as possible and end with a laugh
as quick as possible and in my opinion
you want to open with a joke you're most
confident in that's going to give you
that confidence
that's going to help you attack the
stage and most importantly
help the audience to get on your side
that much faster
because the sooner the audience is
laughing not only are they more
confident in you
more importantly you are more confident
in you and you are more confident in
your ability to
do this set to its fullest potential
a quote i heard from my interview with
alonzo bowden was
he said if you're afraid to say it
they're afraid to hear it
so that's a super crucial point to keep
in mind when you're performing on stage
there's a lot of confidence
when it comes into your delivery but
step one is opening with a confident
joke that you know works to get the ball
rolling in your tight five minute set
all right number two we have three
minutes left here
ish three minutes ish well now less than
three jolt because you're just staring
at the countdown timer
anyway second up you want to laugh
every 20 seconds that's a good metric to
start with
three laughs per minute one laugh every
20 seconds
yes my liberal arts degree taught me
math
um you can do more of course but three
laps per minute is a great baseline a
very attainable
way to start tightening your set going
for three laps per minute now as you
excel
you'll see headliners remember ralphie
may would have 8
10 12 laughs per minute you watch these
just behemoth that's not a fat joke just
behemoth headliners the legends out
there
they're hitting several laps per minute
over an hour
time but let's start small and
incremental and sustainable
in your tight five minute set go for a
laugh
every 20 seconds and your opening joke
you want to get a laugh as quick as
possible
10 seconds 15 seconds in you want to get
them as quick
as possible third
transcribe your set write your joke
completely out this is going to help you
in a few ways it's going to help you to
remember
your jokes it's going to help you to
remember your set
but it's also going to add a visual to
what your set actually looks like and
this is a little hack here
people say transcribe your set okay and
then what
transcribe your set and then go back and
bold
and underline trent just whatever
annotate whatever you want
where your punch lines are where you
think your punch lines are
so now you have a visual representation
of your set and how many laughs you're
expecting to get
so now you can visually see oh there's a
laugh at the top of this page and not
another one till the bottom of this page
how can i get those last closer together
or how can i add more laughs in between
them
fourth rehearse rehearse rehearse
rehearse when i started out in comedy
over 10 years ago i would be rehearsing
in the shower i would be rehearsing
on the way to the show i would be
rehearsing while doing dishes i just
burn it into my brain
and a great tip i like to do is also
rehearse with distractions
rehearse while multitasking rehearse
while driving and having loud music
playing
just because when you're on stage you
might get distracted but if you've
rehearsed with those distractions built
in
you're going to be less likely to derail
your set as you're rehearsing and
rehearsing is just
performing your set going through it
like a script
fifth and final
you gotta do it on stage kids you have
to do it on stage
listen there are so many different
comedy
resources out there for you to learn the
craft i mean
even our podcast alone we have over 400
interviews with professional comedians
and even on this youtube channel you get
a lot of quick tips
but you gotta do it on stage at the end
of the day
you can take the classes you can take
the workshops
which we all have as well but at the end
of the day
none of those will work unless you do so
you have to get on stage you have to
record your set you have to review your
set
and you have to put in that work comedy
is a language you can only learn
through the submersion of stage time
so now you know how to create a type 5
minute set now you got to put it to work
if you'd like to continue this
conversation we have a free facebook
group
where comics around the world are
talking comedy and really helping each
other in their
daily grind holding each other
accountable we also do a live writing
club in there and so much more
so if you want to level up your comedy
and really continue this conversation
over in our free facebook group
go into the description of this video
click join the facebook group
and i'll see you there